[Music]
hello chess fans welcome to chess
openings explained
i'm your instructor tonight nick risco
i'm one of the instructors here at the
chess club
and tonight we're going to be going over
uh the owens
defense it's a 1v6 after one e4
and i think this is probably the first
opening where i can say
that big names have played these lines
names like nakamura
gurayev rajabhav yvonne chuck
aman hamilton even
ali reza farouja plays some of these
lines that we're going to cover tonight
so hopefully this will give a lot of
good ideas to everybody
watching tonight i think there's some
really cool ideas to be learned from
both sides
uh so like i said the opening starts
after
1e4 and then pawn to b6
and this does not follow you know
most popular opening principles black is
not
trying to go and claim space in the
center right away
they're not even trying to go with
knight f6 claiming the center
uh so 1b6 what exactly is black trying
to do
well very clearly they're setting up a
fianchetto for the light squared bishop
to maybe control this diagonal put some
pressure on e4 later in the future
and then only later after seeing what
white setup is
black is going to decide what structure
is going to be best for them
so here white should play pawn to d4
now i know when we were talking about
the nimzovich defense a few weeks ago
i said you know don't play d4 but uh the
difference is that here in the owens
defense
e5 is not a move that black should be
able to get away with
making white commit to a structure
that's worse for them
they should just be able to push or take
the bond
so after pawn to d4 you know your
opponent gives you space in the center
might as well take it
we see black play bishop to b7
this is just the move every player who
plays the on defense plays
just getting that fiance taken care of
early and here we reach
the first position where white has a
decision
there are a few moves here we will
start off with probably the second most
popular knight to c3
on the previous move black has attacked
the e4 pawn so white
just wants to defend and instead of
playing pawn to f3 which can get in the
way of your knight and your queen
white's just going to go knight to c3
and protect with
the knight a fine move and from here
black normally plays where to go
black normally plays pawn to e6
probably going for an eventual d5 push
where the bishop will help support
and also stopping whites from playing
pawn to d5 gaining space
and here there are two moves by white
one that
looks natural the other one not so much
so we will start with the one that
doesn't look so natural but players
should still be aware of
is that white can play pawn to a3
and one of the ideas of this is just to
stop the bishop from coming and pinning
the knight
because once you know if black plays a
bishop to b4
this knight is going to no longer be
protecting our pawn on e4
and become a weakness so that is why you
may see white
play a3 here black is going to follow up
by putting pressure on e4 white is just
going to
defend and pawn c5 we see a break
with this pawn trying to chip away at
the center
white can now go knight f3 uh and this
is fine
we didn't put the bush or we didn't put
the pawn on f3 blocking the knight and
the knight will
protect d4 you may see a trade on d4
followed by knight c6
white can just trade knights and
enjoy a slightly better position after
e5 where they will have space
advantage it's going to be pretty hard
for black just to kind of push and break
through past this e5 pawn
you see like knight to d5 and instead of
trading
with a space advantage you don't want to
trade off pieces
you just go knight to e4 and it's going
to be looking to probably land on d6 in
the future
and this line was featured in prada
scar moau in a correspondence game all
the way back in 1989
so one of the older lines from tonight
but back to this position after pawn to
e6 we're going to start seeing some more
names we're familiar with we're going to
go down a couple of lines that
nakamura and grave and rajib and ivan
chuck have played
starting with knight 2 f3 this one seems
much more natural you might see a lot of
probably scholastic players be playing
moves like this the e4 d4
knight c3 and f3 because this is
probably the ideal setup the knights
just go to their natural squares they
support the center
and you'll be seeing moves like bishop 2
c4
maybe bishop e3 or f4 depending on what
the position demands
you will normally see the bishop come to
b4 this was the idea
that a3 was trying to stop in our
previous line
uh you'll see whites go bishop d3 is
completely fine
again you know with with this pin the
knight is no longer going to be
supporting the e4 pawn so we do have to
reinforce it
but this comes with us developing our
bishop with white being able to castle
on the next move you'll see knight f6
putting more pressure on now again don't
be fooled this is
not a protected pawn the knight is not
actually defending pinned pieces
do not protect the defense of a pinned
piece
is only imaginary so here
you have to play queen e2 that way uh
your queen will protect the pawn on e4
so just don't get caught up in you know
the quickness
of your development you do need to make
sure you are maintaining your pawn
center
after queen to e2 black normally plays
pawn to d5
this was another idea that we were
talking about earlier again putting
another
attacker on e4 and this is trying to
force white
to make a decision on how they are going
to handle their center
one idea is just trading on d5
you can open up the position like this
after knight takes
you have to go bishop d2 to support the
knight enough
without needing to give up a pawn or
even an exchange
if you're not careful so bishop to d2
knight c3 and pawn takes c3 this bishop
is good enough
on this diagonal here if you take on c3
this offers black the chance to trade
and there really doesn't seem to be a
reason to give away
one of your bishops this early in the
game
it might be more beneficial keep it on
the board and see what potential this
bishop holds in the future
so we take with the pawn forcing the
bishop to move back it normally goes to
e7
keeping an eye on this g5 square we do
have a knight
and a bishop on that square and now we
see castles from both sides
this position should be pretty balanced
but one move that is seems to be very
popular at the top level
is pawn to e5 um i don't know why i have
a dubious
mark on that um let me remove that real
quick
uh i don't think i can say it's dubious
if the world's best players are playing
it
uh maybe i i had the intention of
putting interesting move
but here after pawn to e5 there is
knight to e4 the knight just comes in
you have to be very aggressive you don't
just want to go back to d7
it might be a bit tricky to get your
knight to c6 and off of c6 to play c5 in
the future
and it's really hard to tell where this
knight is going
it could go to f8 and g6 but it's a very
long
plan it's much better just be aggressive
put that knight on e4
and watch white play bishop to d2
bishop to d2 is a good move
i do want to mention castles and this is
the move that
uh like nakamura rajab have played
so castles and we see knight takes c3
pawn takes c3
bishop takes c3 and we realize that
white is sacrificing a pawn here
they sacrifice their b-pawn they're
going to play rook to b1
and this can lead to a very i guess
unclear
position you can see this idea of a
sacrifice in many lines where
you know black is going to play e6 and
d5
this pawn sacrifice does pop up i
believe there's also a very similar
sacrifice in the terrace variation of
the french that we looked at last week
so for those of you who are who have
been watching the openings explained
series
might be familiar with this idea already
so that was e5 and then after knight e4
bishop d2 knight takes d2 we see
queen takes d2 um you might be thinking
why are you putting your queen in the
way of your king with this bishop here
as long as you don't move this knight
you're going to be just fine
you're going to castle um and then play
like a3 to kick the bishop out
one of the many possible continuations
here for black this is where it
kind of branches out but one that i
thought was really interesting was
pawn to c5 looking like you're trapping
the bishop
so if white plays pawn to a3 they can't
really go back to a5 i i guess it's
possible
but black is probably going to be better
off trading the bishop for the knight
because with all the pawns on the dark
squares here it's hard to see any hope
for that bishop and this position
should also be pretty balanced
okay so let's go back uh that covers
the uh knight c3 ideas so those are
like the main ideas for white i do want
to cover
some of the other third move
alternatives
i guess there's one other big one and
this is actually a move that uh
our very own jonathan shrantz has
covered recently
with the nasal boss gambit which is
bishop to g5 and
the idea is you're gambiting your e-pawn
and what what is the purpose of this why
is white just giving away a center pawn
for what seems like no compensation
there's this very interesting idea that
was brought up of
pawn to d5 and now the bishop cannot go
back to b7
where it wants to be it wants to be on
this very long diagonal
but after pawn to d5 this bishop is
going to have to settle
with the b1 to h7 diagonal
not saying that's a bad thing it's just
black needs to keep that in mind
uh it will not be able to go back to
where it came from
the most popular continuation is pawn 2
h6
and bishop 2h4 just moving the bishop
out of danger bishop's going to come to
g3
after we see pawn to g5
now here the mouse sorry the most
natural move
might be bishop to g3 you know bishop's
attacked you got to move it out of
danger makes a lot of sense
but there is the alternative knight to
c3
which is actually slightly better if you
go bishop g3
right away black does have this line
where they can get a little bit of an
advantage
so here after bishop g7 if we see knight
to c3
first then black can take
double white's pawns play knight f6
hitting the d5 pawn white is forced to
play
c4 to hold on and pawn to d6
white's pawn structure is a little messy
on the queen side
so there are going to be weaknesses
there for black to hit in the future
this knight can go to a6 or d7 to c5 get
a nice outpost because there are no
b or d pawns to kick it away
so to avoid this bit of a messy
structure
you will see white go knight c3 first
and the idea is if black takes your
bishop on h4
the knight is going to take on e4 and
here
black has the doubled pawns on the rook
file which in an end game
probably are not going to be the most
useful and this knight is on e4 in the
center with nothing there to really
attack it right away
it should be noted f5 cannot be played
to attack the knight
because of queen h5 mate
uh so here after knight c3 you will
normally see the bishop go
back to g6
and here now white will move the bishop
to g3
and the big difference here is just that
black has not had the time to play
bishop to
g7 so they cannot take the knight and
force the doubling of the pawns
after bishop to g7 you'll see knight to
f3
and here if they take on c3 it's not
going to be
as bad black doesn't seem to have the
activity that they do with the bishop on
e4
because now after knight to f6
you have bishop d3 offering to trade the
bishops right away which is possible
you have h4 trying to chip away at the
king side
because the queen is the only defender
that you need on this pawn you don't
need to play
c4 to hold on to it right here so white
still retains that
that tempo they're not forced to play c4
um and that looks to be most of the
theory
on the nasal loss gambit uh it is still
relatively unknown so it's not like
there's a whole bunch of theory out
there
to look at it
but yes everyone should be aware of this
move if they're wanting to play the
owens defense as
black those are the two major third move
alternatives
so bishop g5 the nasal boss gambit we
just looked at
and earlier we looked at knight to c3 so
both of these
are very good third move alternatives
worth a shot for white but the main move
we're going to look at
is bishop to d3 this is probably the
most
flexible move for white it leaves this
knight open to go to f3 or e2
is allowed to go to e2 because we've
already developed the bishop
and then this knight on b1 can go to c3
or d2 depending on if we want to
support our center with c3 if the
position demands
and here black does have a few
alternatives
so the first move here
by black which i i just want to point
out because it has been played before
it's just flat out losing is pawn to f5
uh this is the matavinsky gambit
and if white is not prepared they they
do
have some problems but here you can just
learn the refutation to it and never
have to worry about
complicated positions with
this i wouldn't say it's easy to find
over the board
but it makes sense after you see the
line
we first start off with pawn taking
if it's a gambit we can accept and now
bishop takes g2 this is the idea they
are attacking the rook
and trying to win a rook here in the
position white has this move
queen to h5 check which gives the
compensation
for this rook that they are looking to
give up
pawn to g6 is the only move here there's
nowhere for the king to move
and now we have pawn takes g6
we are threatening pawn to g7 or pawn
h7 mate so here
black does have to do something about it
and there are a few different moves here
i think the first one i have on my list
is
bishop to g7 it's probably the only real
try
if they take the rook again g7 mate
they can try knight f6
uh and here we get into uh g takes h7
check and then after the knight takes
the queen
you have bishop to g6 mate and this is
actually a miniature
given by greco so those who are familiar
with greco i believe he's an italian
composer
this came from an example given in 1620
so if you thought that you know the
1900s were old for correspondence games
we're seeing examples from the 1600s
here tonight
so they can't go knight f6 the only try
for black
is to go bishop to g7
and here white should just take on h7
with check the king is forced to go to
f8 and
the key move here is knight to f3
and after every response white is
looking at a crushing attack
so we will start with what if the bishop
takes on h1
this is what black was wanting all along
when they offered the gambit
white can follow up with knight to e5
and now if bishop takes e5 de5
and here you are going to be
pretty fine after something like queen
over to f5
check uh here white can there's this is
black's move black almost has to give up
the rook and the bishop can take if they
don't give up the rook if they
make some move like bishop d5
then you can take on g8 making a queen
and then if rook takes bishop h6 is
going to lead to mate and
4 and then if king tate
it's going to be mate and 7 after queen
g6 with
very similar ideas of bringing the
bishop into h6
and if rook takes then queen takes
king f7 and queen h7
this is maton three after like king e8
bishop g6 your your checkmating here
um but it shouldn't be too hard to find
those mating threes
over the board you just need to get to
the position where they exist
um so if they don't take on h1
let's say they go knight f6 attacking
the queen
you have to remember to go queen to g6
getting the queen out of danger you're
also hitting the bishop
so now it makes sense for the bishop to
take on h1
there is bishop to h6 looking to take on
g7 with the queen
um take on h8 after and just clear out
the king side here for black
the rook is known to take on h7
there's also bishop takes h6 which is
losing
queen h6 king f7 knight g5 leads to
maiton one
with bishop to g6 uh so rook h7
knight to g5 you're threatening matan
one with the queen
with the knight supporting you're also
threatening to take on h7
here if queen e8 then knight h7
with check and here is maiden one with
queen to g7
this was played in the game harab nasser
versus ahmed in 2019
so yes these positions are from games uh
a better try is bishop takes h6 but this
is also
forced mate in seven after knight takes
h7
knight takes h7 and you have to remember
queen takes h6 trek if you don't
remember this move it's just going to be
in equal position
king has to go to f7 queen h7 check
king e6 is going to be the best
continuation for black with mate and 4
and uh the solution here is queen g6
king d5
knight c3 check getting some of our
final pieces in the attack
uh and it looks like he might be
escaping after king takes d4
but there is this move queen to g5
which leads to matin one after every
black response
with um the move queen to e3
so there really is no good way for black
to survive after pawn to f5 you may
still see it as a trick in blitz
tournaments
but you should be prepared now
after your opponent plays f5
okay so no pawn f5 just given the
refutation
the other move by black um
they can play g6 but this will lead to a
hippo
and that has different ideas than the
owens defense so i'm not going to cover
it
the hippo is going to be a setup for
black with bishop to g7
you're going to play pawns to e6 and d6
and the knights to the center
but like i said we're not going to cover
that tonight the ideas
are different so
i guess that leaves the only good option
for black if they're not wanting to play
the main line
is pawn to d6 and after pawn to d6
uh yes they can still transpose to a
hippo after a couple moves but
there actually is a line here which
isn't a hippo they can play
so after a move like knight f3 knight to
d7
white king castle and black has been
trying to play e5
instead of e6 so this knight
is supporting and this is where
we get that idea of pawn to c3 so this
is one of those positions where
you know we're like okay good we didn't
play knight c3 because now
we can support our center with a pawn
now if they capture we can recapture
with pawn and then we have a two on one
in the center
so that being said black doesn't
normally take here they just continue
developing with knight
g2f6 getting ready to go bishop e7
castle put pressure in the center
white should reinforce their center it
is being attacked by two pieces
so rook to e1 and now pawn to g6
the bishop is going to look to go to g7
now
add more pressure to d4
but here white has this very interesting
move
bishop to g5 where after bishop to g5
this knight is pinned so it can't really
move out of the way for the bishop to
put pressure on d4
it makes it a little bit tough for black
just to maneuver their pieces
so you'll see them play h6 trying to
kick the bishop away
bishop to h4 maintaining the pin and now
after g5 bishop g3
white is going to have a little bit of
trouble getting this bishop active but
with
you know these trades in the center it
shouldn't be too terribly difficult
the threat is going to be when black
plays pawn to h5 looking to play pawn to
h4
so here white has to play h4 themselves
so black cannot play it if they try and
go
h3 pawn to h4 is still going to be good
for black you retreat the bishop to h2
and now pawn g4 you're looking to
just give up this pawn trade it off to
open up
lines for your position and here
black does have some some pressure here
on the king side the queen can't come in
right away because of the knight on f3
but that's going to be some of the ideas
black has here
so that's why white needs to play h4
just so
black can never play it themselves and
now you'll see
pawn to g4 and then knight f to d2
after bringing it back white does have a
bit of a comfortable position after
stopping this attack
and here computer evaluations are giving
it
about plus one
so pawn to d6 is another idea again
very sharp with these kingside pawn
pushes if white
is not prepared they can fall into
trouble very quick
okay bishop d3 now we're going to look
at the main line here
we have pawn to e6 so
we just looked upon d6 g6 transposes to
a hippo
we're going to be looking at e6 now
and after e6 white uh
again has uh i guess it's just one main
move here they do have many moves they
can play c3
they can go uh a3 like before just
avoiding any bishop b4 in the future
but the most popular move here is knight
to f3
and black has decisions now there's
three moves here played by very big
names
oops i actually messed up my nose here
there's one main move
with a couple variations inside of it
pawn to d5
and this is a move that has been played
by ali reza farouja and hikaru nakamura
so they play pawn to d5 here white will
normally play pawn to e5
closing up the center just saying hey
black
you you blocked in your bishop here
and here we see a split between what the
two very strong players play
hikaru has played pawn to c5 multiple
times here
where white just defends the pawn with a
pawn as we've seen before
knight develops to e7 and
here uh nakamura has played queen to c8
as well instead of just knight to e7
white's fine after castle bishop a6
but c4 is going to be a move that really
helps them fight
in the center knight e7
to help support and then knight c3 white
does have a comfortable lead here
and then again after 97 just castles
white's going to be fine with the space
advantage
sandra shock is saying in the comments
it looks like the tarash
that line we just looked at with c4 and
yeah there are a lot of captures here
with these pawns here on the c and d
files
does resemble a tarash system
uh let's see instead of c5
nakamura plays it i can't bash on it too
much
like i said white does have a
comfortable advantage
um and i think kokaro has been playing
against
players much lower rated i could be
wrong on that but
it does exist the other move that exists
the move that ferugia has played before
is bishop to a6 and
it looks like black is going for a trade
on asics
just getting white's light square bishop
off the board
which can be beneficial for black
because white's pawns are on the dark
colored squares
but with this space advantage white is
okay making this trade
the knight is a little misplaced black's
going to have to give a little bit
of work a little bit of effort to
reroute this knight to a better square
you'll see like pawn to c3 just building
up a huge
pawn chain queen to d7
maybe looking to castle queenside side
not entirely clear white can castle king
side you'll see pawn to c5
and pawn to a3 leads to a bit of a
unclear position this is also a line
that
amman hamilton has played with the black
pieces
okay a lot of options here for both
sides
so e6 knight f3
but the main move here is c5 challenging
in the center
right away pawn to c5 is
striking at d4 it is protected by the
knight
the question is if white has to do
anything about this
or if they can let it if they can let it
sit
here there is a
not really a transposition but a way to
kind of get out of
some of these big space french-like
positions
i guess like french advance for white if
white
castles here it can lead to a lot of
sicilian-like
positions after pawn takes knight takes
you'll see this starts to resemble you
know open c file
uh the d-pawn is missing knight is on d4
you see knight to c6 there can be a
trade
knight to c3 and bishop to c5 and this
is um
almost like an e6 sicilian with b6 and
bishop b7 played
so yeah white can play castles there if
they are
comfortable with open sicilian positions
it's going to resemble those
the other option they have is just
support the pawn with c3 again
if black takes just recapture with your
c pawn
and this is a line that black has played
before in a couple games but
doesn't really work out too well for
them after white takes back with c4
or i guess with the c pawn on d4
there are two moves black has played in
the past
we'll start with knight f6 putting
pressure on the e pawn
white just defends with the knight and
bishop to b4
pinning so again like we've seen in
some of the earlier variations the
defense
with a pinned piece is but imaginary so
this knight's not helping out you have
to play queen e2 to defend your center
pawn to d5 pawn to e5
closing up the center again and knight
to e4 so this is a maneuver that we've
seen before
we get castles from white and we get
another
chance for a pawn sacrifice here if
black
takes on c3 rook b1 staring on this
half open b file this is also
supposed to be very good for white i'm
not too familiar why
this position is considered winning for
white engines giving it
plus two and a half uh or plus 2.7
depending on how long you let it think
um so i'm not sure what the difference
is between this position and the
previous position where there was this
sacrifice but in this variation
let it be known that you shouldn't take
on c3
you should just go bishop to e7 white is
still going to be better here
plus one 1.7 here
so not the best black can get with the
owns defense
but white should still be prepared if
they face this knight f6 move
the other move that black has is bishop
to b4
check and this is a bit more of an
aggressive option here
just coming for the king right away
knight to c3
can lead to transpositions to the other
lines with
the bishop coming to b4 and pinning the
knight is just we're getting there in a
different move order
we get knight f6 queen e2
pawn d5 e5 knight e4 castles
bishop c3 a little bit different
if the knight takes we end up in the
same position that we just looked at
where like knight c6 can be played and
bishop a3 stopping black from castling
otherwise black can take on c3 first
with the bishop and then after pawn
takes the knight can take
we see queen to e3 queen's attack we
have to do something about it
we castle and here
white has a greek gift sacrifice that
will help them
win the game bishop takes h7
check this position is already plus four
plus five now king takes h7
knight to g5 check for those familiar
with this trap
this isn't going to be new to you guys
and we see
queen to h3 looking to go to h7
best move for black is check king h1
but now in order to stop the checkmate
rook e8 isn't going to work after queen
h7 king f8
there's bishop a3 which gets rid of the
escape square
you have to block so like giving up the
queen or if you try blocking with the
queen on e7 just queen h8 is made
so there are opportunities for white to
heavy greek
gift sacrifice as well
okay um so taking on c sorry taking on
d4 with the c
pawn is possible i cannot recommend it
for black
i have not seen a line where black
equalizes
uh with that being said black should
play
knight to f6 in this position leave the
pawn tension there's absolutely no
reason to get rid of it
prematurely you don't want to take and
give up
tension unless there is a very good
reason for it
okay knight f6
what does white do after knight f6 well
they're putting pressure on our e4 pawn
bishop and knight are attacking so we
have to defend
now here there are two options you can
go queen e2
or you can go knight d2 but i have to
recommend queen to e2
we have not developed the dark square
bishop yet so
i i can't recommend knight d2 because
this knight cannot easily move away
this pawn is going to be facing pressure
until you play e5 but when you play e5
you give up a little bit of the space
control
where here you are controlling two
squares three with
the pawn on d4 when you play pawn to e5
you're still controlling e5 but it's
because it's occupied
which makes this pawn on d4 i guess less
flexible in how you're handling
anything happening in the center
uh with knight d2 like i said can't
really move easily
and it's going to be tough to get the
dark square bishop out so just go queen
e2
this dark square bishop is going to get
out to f4 g5
maybe e3 you know the the opportunity
for that is going to be low with the
pressure on e4
but you want to retain maximum
flexibility
for your pieces so queen e2
recommended move here bishop to e7
don't really want to put it on d6 you
don't want to block your center pawn
from advancing
and here white just does have the tactic
pawn to e5
so if you are developing you just have
to go to e7 this is okay
you're preventing any pins on g5
from the bishop i guess black also has a
couple
other moves here instead of bishop e7
it looks like there is the move pawn to
d5 right away
so as i was mentioning you don't want to
block the pawn you do want to advance it
in the future you can play d5 here
running into pawn e5
uh you have to push it because now
there's three attackers and you don't
want to play knight d2 defending
blocking your bishop so
it's best just to move it out of the way
you have to make this
this advanced you do get this open
diagonal
though knight after d7
bishop g5 getting the dark square bishop
out with
tempo black just blocks and
here uh you know where does white's
bishop want to go does it really want to
go back behind its own pawn does it want
to go to e3 and block
block the queen from getting out in the
future you can't really put it on d2
that's where your knight wants to go
and it would look almost silly to put it
back on c1 just because you're
undeveloping
so you'll see white exchange here
queen takes castles from white
knight c6 first putting pressure on the
center before
castles and here uh i believe i have it
marked as a novelty
i couldn't find a game with this played
queen to e3 just supporting the center
and white should be comfortable here no
significant advantage it's not like
there's any crazy king side attacks here
but white should just stand a little bit
better
okay the other move they have
which i've marked as a mistake instead
of bishop e7
is knight to c6 and the reason this is a
mistake
is because now white can start pushing
pawns in the center and get their pawns
rolling
pawn to d5 is going to attack the knight
it's attacking the center
if black takes this is a big problem
after e takes d5 there's this check on
the king
sure you can block with the queen but
you're going to lose a knight in the
process
if you block with the knight well white
just pushes
pawn to d6 and they are winning a piece
so knight to c6 uh if you have the white
pieces just be aware you can get the
pawns going
uh if they have not castled yet there
are some discoveries
okay back to bishop e7 we looked at the
alternatives here
bishop e7 probably gives the most
promising position
for the player with the black pieces and
here oops looks like i moved the page
okay here is where
i have my personal disagreements with
what the main line is
the main line here white castles
uh let's see yes white castles here
this is the main line i can't say
anything is wrong with this
it's been tried and tested scores great
here you will see knight 2 c6 putting
more pressure on d4
and you'll get pawn to a3 and this is
just you don't want black to take and
then play a knight to b4
there are ideas where after takes takes
the pawn is no longer protecting b4 so
the knight will come trying to attack
the bishop
a3 is stopping this idea
and then you'll see knight to a5 looking
to come to b3
so knight to d2 here uh you do block
your bishop but it is to stop
this attack on the rook
protecting against this forking idea
pawn to c4 attacking the bishop and
bishop just drops back to c2
there is the move takes with the knight
and after knight takes bishop takes and
bishop takes e4
this is still okay for white i don't
recommend it you're giving up a center
pawn
and i i don't like the idea that we are
just
giving that up for the c pawn
so bishop to c2 instead just keeping
everything solid
and now something like queen c7
protecting the pawn
rook to e1 castles rook to b1
probably looking to go b4
rook a2 e8 um
honestly this move is a little beyond me
i'm not entirely sure
why it's this rook coming all the way
over i'm assuming it's just there's no
like way black can push through on the
queen side and get this work active
so they bring it to the center looking
for uh
if white plays d5 they trade and they
have a rook on a file
or they may be trying to push themselves
and if anyone has any knowledge in that
position feel free to drop it in the
comments
knight 2f1 here rerouting the knight
pawn to d6
prepping maybe e5 knight to g3 this is
like a maneuver that we've seen
in the rui lopez the italian
very classical night maneuver and now
pawn to e5
by black and white has a healthy
advantage here
some moves they can play is like pawn to
h3 there's bishop to e3
many many moves that lead to a fine
position
and this was from the game cermak
philippovic
where white won in 1999
however i said i can't uh can't always
agree with the main line i feel like
there is a better move
than castles here and
i'm giving that move an exclamation mark
pawn to e5 i really like aggressive
openings
i feel playing e5 is the most aggressive
approach i'm gonna go for e5
after e5 black does have to move the
knight they can't just let it sit
and hang they cannot really take on f3
because after bishop takes f3
they can't just leave this knight here
and they can't really just move it to h5
because of something like queen takes a8
so they would still have to go knight d5
and it's
you know you don't want to give up your
pieces uh prematurely you want to make
sure you're making the most of your
pieces all the time
and this bishop does look better than
this knight
so here knight to d5
should be played and now we have this
move
pawn to c4 attacking the knight again
being very aggressive the knight has two
squares it can go to it can go to c7
and then white will get knight to c3 and
here you may see
black capture because here there is cd4
and if the queen i mean like the queen
can't take it's protected by the knight
so
blast is going to get the center pawn
here so
taking should be fine for black here
so knight c7 is worth a try
if black is trying to be aggressive and
go knight to b4
then i feel bishop to e4 is a good move
for white
trying to trade off the light square
bishops
queen to c7 defending you don't really
want white to take here because
after bishop takes queen takes if you
try and take on d4
and give up the rook you're gonna fall
just a little
short knight c2 is going to try and win
it back but after king e2 knight takes
e1
the knight is looking a little trapped
after queen e4
it's uh not easy to see how the knight
is going to get out
and ideally white is going to win that
night in the future
we see a uh greg consolini bringing in a
ben
feingold reference here c4
is explosive definitely trying uh so yes
bishop e4 looking to trade
queen c7 because you don't want to to
get your knight trapped in the corner
forever
and here we're going to continue being
aggressive we're going to go pawn a3
attack the knight again and
here there there's really it's really
tough to find
a correct move for white but bringing
the knight back to c6
gonna probably have to be the best try
but now
pawn to d5 the pawns keep rolling
if knight takes e5 uh you know you can
sacrifice
um this pawn give it up just go knight
c3
after takes probably bishop takes
here i found even though white is down
upon
massive activity with the pieces
is coming the bishop is going to come in
have a purpose
white's going to castle it's just all
the pieces are doing things
and here i think the move that i have
which is testing
for black if they're not going to
retreat the knight
one other try is bishop takes e4
and this should be losing for black
after
queen takes e4 queen c6
you know a way to protect the rook is
just by putting a piece in the way
and now instead of trading queens you
don't want to trade queens the knight
can recapture this is equal
just queen e2 protect against the knight
trek
the knight has to go back to a6 now
both sides castle and knight c3
and white is better here position is
plus 2
the knights are developed the bishop is
going to come out
when it's ready get the rooks to the
center this pawn
center is ready to get rolling this
position is really great
this has not been played um in any games
that i know of
this was a line that i found from
messing around with the engine while
preparing for this
for this lecture originally i was going
to just say you know
castles main line play it it's great
still great but i did find that this
line
with pawn to e5 just being very
aggressive
and rather forcing does lead to very
great chances for whites and i wanted to
make sure that
that was out there and people could see
it so
this line does exist
uh but that is all the theory i have
prepared for you guys tonight
uh and just like last time we're going
to open up the last 10 to 15 minutes
here to any questions
in the chat we do have a lot of people
in the chat
compared to last week so let's start
scrolling through see if there's any
questions about our opening
is the owens defense even good in
classical games
my opinion is that if you're below over
the board rating of 2000 your openings
while it's good to have a plan are not
crucial because
people blunder you know at the amateur
level
everyone blunders you know if you're
rated fifteen hundred and you never
blunder
why are you rated fifteen hundred um
so everyone blunders at some points
you're going to end up leaving theory
and people have chances to make mistakes
so
uh for the amateur i i think i can say
yes
the owens defense is good you might end
up in some
tough positions where you're gonna have
to fight a little bit
against white space and some of their
activity but
it should be playable and i i can't say
it's not playable because you have
very strong grandmasters playing both
sides of this opening
so i can't say that uh it's horrible
in classical games though there is the
opinion that
the owens is a bad defense as as claimed
by ghana in the chat
um i i can't say it's complete garbage
i think it's almost losing by force but
not quite
there are lines where black does have a
very
solid fight
so yes i think uh surreal is also saying
something along the lines like this
isn't a super serious opening that black
plays
yeah this is not the most popular
opening from black but it's
very good to at least study it as white
know what you're getting into
very similar to the alkyne defense where
people are like oh it's not a major
opening don't need to study it
you should always go through and study
it anyway because you don't want to get
into this situation where you don't
treat it seriously because you assume
it's horrible
and then you know start losing the game
just because you're overconfident you
want to make sure you still have that
plan
of what you are doing
so that's that's probably my opinions on
on the owens defense right there
let's see what else is in the chat
uh we're seeing stuff about the bononi
and the banco gambit there's not this
opening so i'm not gonna answer
questions about those
um let's see i guess there was a debate
in the chat on why the owens is good or
or bad uh see the scandinavian coming up
we see the blackmart deemer gambit
showing up
uh in the levitsky attack those are
openings that are in the works right now
uh sandro shock is asking about pinning
the f6 knight also an option
there is no move number so i don't
exactly know where to look so
sandro if you want that question
answered please include a move number so
i know what line you're talking about
i manny's asking if the owens defense is
approved in classical games
from super gms um i
i don't remember if they were classical
games or if they were blitz and rapid
but
yes the owens has been played by super
gms
with the black pieces again
hikaru nakamura and alareza farouja have
lines that we've covered
uh to do so yes more people asking is
this played in the gm levels
yes grandmasters do play this opening
there are games by famous players in
this opening
i'm done saying that so i'm gonna stop
saying it
um doesn't look like
there are any other questions about the
owens
uh george lethbridge is asking would
this be advisable
for a 1b3 player i do like the question
so let's go back to the opening position
here on our board
one b6 and one b3 may have very similar
ideas in the fact that your bishop is
going to be
going to fianchetto itself
um i i don't know how similar they are
beyond that
because i know that black can have some
very aggressive setups with
e5 d6 and f5 whereas here
with the owens there aren't many lines
where we're going to be seeing
white play pawn to f4 i'm sure they
exist
i'm not saying they don't exist i'm not
saying that those lines are bad for
whites
i'm just saying those were not the lines
that i prepared tonight
so it could be advisable i think um
though the the problem is going to come
down to who has the first move
so white can uh play b3 and get away
with
some of this a bit of slower development
in the center
because they have this first move
advantage black does not have that
luxury of the first move advantage and
is always going to
feel that half tempo behind
so they're going to be playing catch up
in the center as we saw
black was always preparing e5 they were
always preparing d5 it's not like they
can just play it right away
so you know if you're a 1b3 player i'd
say try it out but i
don't think you can be as aggressive as
you would be
with any b3 lines
all right back to the chat
let's see
talking about other crazy openings here
uh sandro shock was talking about it was
the line where e4 was hanging and the
options were between 92 and knight bd2
okay i i'll come back to that i'll see
if i can find it
um paco zambellini is saying if you play
e6
first as black it's a french defense not
an owen
so it's better question mark
uh yeah if you play e6 first so e4
and pawn e6 that is a french
but in the french you're not typically
going to see a pawn to b6 and the the
bishop fianchetto
in the french defense you're going to
see more e6 and d5 in a direct
fight for the center it's not going to
have the same fiance
ideas that the owens defense features
though i know there are some sidelines
in the french that feature this idea
but uh i think that even you know e6
after you play b6 um is going to be
way different than a french because you
might see pawn to d6 it's not guaranteed
they're going to go pawn to d5
okay um owens defense or owens gambit it
was an overall view of the owens defense
800 rating beginner intermediate not
related to openings but
800 rating typically beginner um
say like 1200 and up is going to be more
of your intermediate level crowd
and we get paco's question again okay so
sandro shock
i'm going to try and find that line
with knight to d2
we'll see if i can find it here
because there were a lot of moments
where the pawn on e4 was under attack
see if i can find it but no guarantees
why can't i find it oh here it is okay
so this is in the main line on move five
where
uh black goes c5 right away and then
they go knight f6 and they're attacking
the pawn
sandra shock is asking about bishop to
g5
here and i don't see any problems with
this move
this move you're still developing your
piece your your pinning
so yes this pin is another way to defend
your e4 pawn
the critical try for black is going to
be playing pawn to
h6 and here the only thing white can do
to to be better is take on f6
so as long as you have the idea of
playing bishop to g5
to trade on f6 yeah go ahead and do it
but this is what happens if you know
white does not
trade if they go bishop to h4
because black has not castled kingside
playing moves like g5 should not be out
of the question white should always be
looking at this
um because the king can castle queen
side if it needs to
it can stay in the center it hasn't
castled to the king side where pushing
g5
is going to be a big weakness and after
pawn to g5
after bishop to g3 e4 does hang
so you'll see something like knight
takes e4 and if you trade the bishop for
the knight
engine's saying this is equal i think
it's going to be a little difficult for
white being upon down
especially with cd looking like it can
be played
but the the the upside here for white is
that white does have the development of
the knight in bishop
and black does have a lot of extended
pawns
they have not taken the time to develop
their pieces
off of the back rank so so that's where
the upside is going to be
if you're not taking on f6 so very good
question from sandro shock here
bishop g5 a fine move i just think you
can get better more active positions
after queen e2
okay back to the chat see if there's any
more questions
is karo khan stronger than the owens i
have to say yes
karo khan probably much stronger only
because it's making that direct
fight for control in the center i know
caleb denby's done a series on the karo
khan
on our youtube channel so check that out
when you have the chance
okay how can i become grand master you
just got to get good
got to get good at chess get a rating
over 2500
get norms all good stuff i'm at 1450
tips to get better these aren't
opening questions but i figured i'll
answer them at 14
50 tips to get better just do your
tactics
just grind tactics on leeches or
chess.com
and do your end game studies surreal is
saying this is a bad
defense for black i have to agree it's
it's not the best defense for black
but it is a very strong uh
not strong uh but it is a very serious
sideline that white players need to look
at unless you're rated over three
thousand
uh it's going to be worth taking a look
at this opening at least
paco no problem i'm always happy to
answer the questions
but yeah here we are wrapping up at the
end of the half hour convenient uh
20 seconds for any last minute questions
here
otherwise we are going to wrap it up
you guys are welcome for the lecture
it's always a pleasure doing it it's
always great when the chat is
interacting
see we're getting some requests for the
kings gambit
we do have a lot of openings that i'm
working on for this lecture series
so we are going to try and get a taste
of everything but if there is something
specific you want to see make sure you
drop it in the comments section below
once this stream is up on youtube
i'm always checking the comments on the
videos to see what people are
recommending
and that is going to be the best way to
make sure that i see it
uh if you're interested in lessons we do
have instructors on our web page
uh i just see some people thinking about
getting lessons we do have instructors
on our web page that
uh cover more than just openings
um seeing more more opening suggestions
i love to see it
this is the end of our uh our hour-long
lecture though so we do have to go
again if you have openings you want to
see drop them in the comments section
below
it was a very fun time giving this
lecture we're going to go over to our
twitch channel where we're doing tactics
i will see you guys
over there thanks for stopping in
you